controlled deterministic rotation of the coin like all the other Gates the hadamard is performed by rotating 90°
around the Y AIS then 180° around the xais so applied to the head's Upstate it
ends up being head's right so there's nothing random about a Quantum superposition state or any of
the standard operation that we perform on the Cubit every operation is deterministic and reversible the only
time Randomness comes into play is when we decide to measure the quantum State whether a Quantum state is even in a
superp position is really just in the eye of the beholder as you've probably encountered we're free to choose our
coordinate system X Y and Z can point along any three orthogonal directions so
if we have a superposition of 0 and one in one coordinate system we can define a new coordinate system or a new so-called
basis in which the state is pointing purely in the plus Z Direction and therefore not in a superposition state
so when we say a cubit is in a super position we must also Define our coordinate system or
basis you may leave this module with the impression that we've just removed all of the mystery from quantum mechanics
after all one of the supposed supposedly weirdest aspects the superposition state of a cubit is really just as simple as a
three-dimensional Vector but keep in mind that the coin is still only an analogy and even the block Vector is
only a visualization tool to calculate the probabilities of the measurement outcomes we can't say what a Quantum
state is really doing before it's measured because checking that requires a measurement we will discuss this
conundrum of what is the true nature of a Quantum State and how the quantum phenomenon of entanglement can help us
elucidate this in another episode of kisd in the classroom all about Bells inequality in the meantime though if you
want to play with Quantum coins to learn for yourself about the superposition states of a cubit and how to control
them head over to the quantum coins module Linked In the description thanks for watching and I'll see you next time